raising a family and being a single mom
at something for so Pailin knows about
we were with the mother of three talking
all about her reality TV return and
putting her personal drama with
ex-husband Dakota Meyer on blast there's
a lot of things that we probably both
wish we would have done differently I
think there's a lot of things that we
would advise our children to do
different we don't know how to hold this
together I'll never say anything bad
about them it's a work in progress and
part of that progress for the now single
mom is starting a new journey and
joining the upcoming season of MTV's
Teen Mom og
Bristol's ex-husband a former Marine
Sergeant who will be featured in the
series suffers from post-traumatic
stress disorder I don't want to raise my
kids to think that this is what a
marriage looks like you know Dakota's
PTSD has always been a known factor I
can't imagine the stuff that he that
he's seen and I'm appreciative of him
doing the show I don't care what he says
about me I do go to bed knowing that I
have given it my own paws before you
play eg was with Bristol eight years ago
on the set of her teen pregnancy
campaign ad Bristol makes clear today
she was never preaching about abstinence
and says her second pregnancy was
planned even though she wasn't married
so there's so many misrepresentation I
think about me and I don't have time to
stay here and try to correct all of them
people don't realize that I've had a
normal job for several years so my life
was pretty figured out I got engaged it
was a planned pregnancy 100% I'm really
fun mom Sarah will also appear on Teen
Mom but you won't see the 27 year old
tying the knot again or will you I don't
think I'd ever get remarried yeah going
through the aftershocks of divorce it's
hard to picture myself getting married
again but I don't know what that work is
I think I'm done but I would totally
adopt in a heartbeat
[Music]